classes classes are new and es6 at least
for javascript a class is a blueprint
from which individual objects are
created classes provide a much simpler
and clearer syntax to create objects and
deal with inheritance one way to define
a class is using a class declaration to
declare a class you use the class
keyword with the name of the class you
can see here this is the class
declaration then pour a part about this
as it just starts with the word class a
class expression is another way to
define a class class expressions can be
named or unnamed the name given to a
named class expression is local to the
class's body so you can see that a may a
class expression starts with the
variable name and for their unnamed and
then the name also starts with a
variable named but then this one has the
class name here the named one the
unnamed does not have the class name but
let's go back up here a little bit I'm
actually gonna paste some code in here
the first thing I want to talk about is
the constructor function the
construction function starts with the
word constructor and I'll have the
variables that you're going to pass in
when you're creating the class and you
can see that I just assigned those
variables that I pass in or that the
data that pass in to be properties of
the function when you say this dot name
equals name now the class is going to
have a property called name and a
property called year born I also have
another function as I put in called get
age when a function starts with get that
means you're going to call this age as a
property and not a function when you
call function you put the parentheses
after it when you call it property
there's no no parentheses I'll give you
an example in just a minute and you can
see that this getter function actually
calls this dot calc age which is down
here so it can actually do a calculation
and send the calculation back as a
property so let me show you an example
down here
if we create a new instance of this
class and I put VIP bar me equals
a person I'm gonna pass in a name and a
year so you can see I put the name of my
new instance of this class and you have
always when you're creating a new
instance you always use a new keyword
and the word person that just comes from
the name of the class up here and then
see in the constructor we have you
passing a name a year born so that's why
I passed in into the new person now now
that I've created it I can actually use
this information let me show you an
example console.log and if I run this
here you can see in the console Bo was
born in 1983 so you can see you can
actually just add these variable names
with with strings and when I call this
meeting that's going to take out the
name Bo that we passed in when we
created the function or when we created
the the instance of the class and we do
meet at your born it's going to call out
the year that we passed in when we
created that that instance you know we
called properties of the instance of the
class me that name but we can also call
functions if you look up here we have
another function what and it's going to
actually log right in the function it
says console dot log this dot name is a
person so if I type in me dot what now
this time I'm gonna have to put the two
parentheses after that I'm calling a
function and not just a property so
let's run that and you can see right in
the console it says the first thing Bo
is more in 1983 and it shows Bo as a
person there's another type of function
we can put in here and that is a static
function so I'm gonna create a new
function I'm going to type in static now
when you put a function in a class and
use the word static
that defines a static method for a class
static methods are called without
instantiating their class and are also
not callable when the classes understand
cheated and static methods are often
used to create utility functions for an
application so here to call the meetup
name meetup what we had to instantiate
it by doing VAR me equals new person but
to call the arms function we don't need
to make an instance of it so let me give
you an example console dot log so as you
can see instead of calling me the arms I
actually called person dot arms so to
call it static function you you put in
the name of the class and then call the
function instead of the name of the
instance of the class which would be me
so let's run there and see what it does
yeah so you says um Bo has two arms can
also pen a space there okay another
thing I want to tell you about it is the
extends keyword the extends keyword is
using the in class declarations or class
expressions to create a class as a child
of another class when you create a child
it can use all the properties and the
functions of the original class but then
you can add some more let me give you an
example so as you can see I've defined
another class called juggler that
extends a person so usually when you're
gonna use the word extends it should be
in is a relationship for instance a
juggler is a person so that's how I
juggler extends person juggler is a
person now you can see in the person
class we have what if you call what it's
going to console that log this name is a
person however then the juggler class
we've redefined the what function and
it's going to say console that log this
name is a juggler so let me show you an
example of how this works but first
we're gonna create a new a new instance
of this juggler class so
so I've created a new instance of the
juggler class I called the juggler Jai
born in 1980 then I called meat out what
that was the original instance of the
person class and now I called you dot
what that's the instance of the juggler
class so let's see what happens I'm hit
run now you can see the last two lines
of the console Bo is a person and J's a
juggler so you can see that for you that
called the the J and the only thing in
the juggler class is the what says
complement log this not name but juggler
doesn't have a this name that's because
it's it's bringing in the vista the dot
name from the person class so this dot
name is a juggler so it changes the what
function depending on if it's the person
or the juggler and the only other thing
I wanted to talk about during this
lesson is the super keyword so if you
add a the word super you can call
functions on an object's parent so the
parent of the juggler class is the
person class so if I type in super dot
what and then I'm going to clear the
console again and now I'm gonna run this
so if you look at the last two lines now
it says J is a person and then J is a
juggler that's where this super dot what
when it says super dot what here it's
calling this command up here console dot
log this name is a person which is
calling J's a person because we're in
the J instance and then when a console
that log this that name is a juggler so
using the super command allows you to
call the the function from the previous
from the parent of the class well thanks
for watching my name is beau Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good